hi friends it's uh lewis again
with some more uh tales um well today i
made um
58 years old the big 5
8 and uh you know laying around
in the bed this morning i was so goddamn
depressed because i'm figuring
58 years of my life and i [__] it off
and i like to blame myself for all the
[__] [__] that i've been through
but when you're a child and you've been
beat
molested ostracized
talked about downed belittled
these are the things that created the
personality which i have today
i'm 58 years old today i got 10 days to
get the [__] out of my place
i keep giving these people a little bit
here a little bit there a little bit
there
a little bit here a little bit there you
know
i'm just
what am i going to do with my [__]
tent
so i'm really depressed my neck so i was
thinking
a few years ago i had a little job where
this guy used to let me
let me watch his cars and he worked at a
real popular place in hollywood he let
me watch his cars you know and
when i walked up to the job i was i was
i was funky i was stinking and my hair
was nappy and
i looked like i entered a bath and i
asked him for a job he gave me a job
and when i told him who my sister was
because she she had done some business
with him before
and then my brother had came down
he said the condition you're in
why won't your family because he's just
from armenia he's he could he it
baffled the [__] out of him why want
your family help you dude i can't i
can't
he said what did you do to them
so bad that they won't help you
and i was thinking to myself no what did
they do to me
to put me in the situation the [__]
that they taught me as a kid that i
wasn't [__] that i won't never be [__]
and the other day i ain't [__] you know
and
i got a i got a sister
who's a [__] cpa i got a brother
who's a longshoreman the son of a [__]
goes to work on sunday makes 700 [__]
dollars for the [__] day
they got big ass houses and everything
drive nice cars and [__]
here in ten days i'm gonna get put on my
[__] house it took me it took
me
it took me oh man it took me so many
years to get this little that's our old
place man and i ain't not the pope
in the po po folks been working with me
man i i i but i just
i've been giving them this yet and the
other and i i just i can't
they said i just said i got to come up
with the whole before i gotta come with
the whole with a whole month sprint
there's no way there's no way i can come
up with 500
so i'm not even going to try so that's
what got me depressed i'm like okay well
thing is where am i going to go what am
i doing with all this [__] in my house
and all this kind of [__] [__]
so now
i'm sitting here thinking i ain't got
nowhere to stay so now all of this [__]
is coming down on me
i was thinking about when i was a kid
when when i when they
left me when i was a kid you know and i
i often thought when i got molested by
these three women
that it was something that that i did
wrong it was something why why
why why i think my lesson on me when my
sister my brothers would sit up and they
would talk about me like a dog they
would talk about me
they would talk about me until i was i
was a big [__] big [__]
and they would talk about me until i
cried they were talking
they got a kick out of that [__] but
they was cutting me they was cutting me
you know
i was looking tv i was i was one of them
serial killers you know and they how he
he had a child
i had a childhood like mine where he got
beat molested and
ostracized and he came out to be a
murderer you know he
he started murdering people and and i i
i didn't i didn't go that way but god
damn i'll be thinking about my woman
what the [__]
i might need 500 what am i going to do
i'm going to rob a [__] am i
going to stand in front of 18 and jack a
[__]
you know my am i going am i going to
stand outside the bank and catch
somebody ready tell her and take their
[__] money
am i going to break into houses like i
used to do i'm too old for that [__] my
knees don't work my arms don't work i
can't [__] see
you know and i i'm too old for all that
[__]
so when i wake up in the morning folks i
ask god
why did you wake me up one more day
because i don't even want to wake up in
the morning
um i have nothing to wake up to
most people on their birthday when they
wake up they
they they wake up into into happiness
and then they see the sun shining they
hear the birds chirping
i wake up in the morning put the cover
back on my [__] head i don't want to
hear you
see [__] i thought oh [__] another
[__] day
i looked in my [__] room today my
rooms everything i know what i'm going
to put out i don't even clean the
[__]
my room was so [__] nasty i couldn't
i couldn't i had i could i couldn't get
through the goddamn door so i tried to
clean this [__] up and said [__] i don't
want to clean
[__] up i moved my refrigerator they got
i got a freezer
move my [__] refrigerator cockroach
just came out front of the [__]
with shots going
straight [__] i'm trying to
sleep you know i'm i mean i was i mean
it it's so nasty in there you know what
i'm saying and i
i i just i'm just confused and and
delirious
you know what i know but i i i always
say
that what's on earth always say
i don't give a [__] nobody calls me
on my birthday that's [__]
that hurts me because these
[__] got all this money
my god i don't even i don't even know
what that [__] phone sounds
like
they won't call me oh
my sister takes care of my daughter
her and that [__] both of them
my brother she has my sister gave her a
car
and a goddamn car something's wrong with
the car so she dropped it she calls him
drops the car at her house he gives her
his best car
and she takes off in his best car and
called me and asked me
[__] and told me [__] so
my brother's telling me about it i said
so i he gets i'm calling her
i'm i'm calling and texting have her
call me call me now call me i'll try to
do anything i can help man for my
daughter man i'll go i'll go
now i'll go jack a [__] i'll go
straight rob the [__] my
daughter mean the money money
straight up so so
they never did call um so i called
myself
so i said why why why don't they call me
you know
am i why don't they call me dude i mean
goddamn
and i you know i don't you know i i look
at people out here
where i'm standing around here and i see
people in huddles you know people
and gangs and people would with i my
main thing
is i've always had a woman i saw me
because my mom left me when i was a
little boy
so that scarred the [__] out of me
scarred the [__] out of me
got the [__] out of me so i have a
tendency to push women away
and subconsciously i pushed away i
remember i told one girlfriend of mine
i said go ahead [__] you're gonna leave
me any [__] way and she said why
would you say that
what's why would you why would you say
i'm gonna leave you all of them [__]
leave
all them [__] leaving all my friends
don't want to be around me the girls
don't want to be around me i'm lonely as
a mother i sit up and i
man i sit up in that place man i don't
give a [__] my monster you got my my
mama think i'm gay
you ain't got a girlfriend yet you got a
girlfriend i ain't got a girlfriend
i i just
don't know how to be social no more
because my depression
gets in the way of everything i start
thinking about
let me tell you about something i did
one time i gotta tell y'all so i gotta
tell y'all so this is something i
never told about i was smoking that
crack one day
i had a white girl when i was going with
she had a 16 year old daughter
and we sitting in on the couch smoke
rack
she's sitting over there in them goddamn
biker shorts and i'm taking his and we
we watching we all sitting there
watching porno together
and i mean oh god we all watching porno
together i had the money
she wanted to crack i said ah what's up
with that
she ordered her daughter give me some
[__] so i'm smoking cracking got this
six-year-old girl
sucking on my [__] i have never
done a life i've never ever
ever ever ever turned away and i think
things the things that i've done
i've done a couple of things like that
in my life and i think the reason why i
do things like that because
resentment so when i was a child i got
molested so i feel like
what makes her better than me what the
[__] makes her bed why can't i get me
some of that young [__] they [__] me
when i was a baby everybody [__] my
family [__] me my friends
playing my neighbor down the street [__]
me the man [__] me but with the train
they all [__] me why why you know why
why i'm i'm i'm [__] up behind this
[__] i'm
[__] up behind this [__] ain't got no
cereal murder but maybe i'm
molester or something i don't know what
the [__] you want to call me you know um
and my sexual appetite this is zero now
one time i want to smoke
on how i'm waiting when i have a second
girl and i'm smoking cracking together
i'm drinking any time like that because
my there's there's there's no no there's
no normality in my mind anymore
i was thinking the other day my god am i
crazy
because i have i have you know i
remember asking somebody a long time ago
i remember seeing somebody crazy and you
know somebody really crazy in the street
and i remember thinking when do they go
from a piece of mind
to a little piece of a mind to no mind
at all
and i'm walking down the street and i
noticed my i noticed that i was talking
to myself
and i went to i went i remember one time
i went to donate plasma and i was
talking to myself
and lady said do we need to evaluate you
because you sound like you crazy because
you talking to yourself
and i started hearing that [__] and i
said damn am i losing my
[__] mind you know i can't remember
anything
i said i take i took the top off the
beach to beat the floor to bleach the
roaches
i took the top and i [__] i don't
know what the way the top is
the room is so [__] small you can
walk in the front door and follow the
[__] back fence and i take the top
off the beach and can't find it
my glasses i'm laying in the [__] bed
with the glasses on
watching tv i roll over go to the brush
or something come back they can't find
the [__] glasses
i can't bring that [__] out oh this is
this is a good one not in our showers
our showers at my place is so [__]
nasty
the room's just the rest don't want to
go up in there so i go in there i don't
want to put my feet i don't like
touching my feet on nobody's
[__] flow
i can't keep up with the [__] sandals
every time i take the sandals off i'll
lose one i swept it down must be a ghost
and they're taking my [__]
[__] god
i couldn't find that [__] shoe i
don't know what i don't know my my i
said
i said i'm gonna take my shower shoes
off i'm gonna sit them right here well i
know
one of them's always missing every time
i try to
do something if i just if i get home and
just throw [__] around the house i can
find it if
i put it in a certain place i can't
remember i can't remember where i
where i i've got i've gotten
this organization got me a really really
really really really expensive pair of
glasses i mean they were nice
because they were really nice glasses
and i remember i was riding a train
and i got off the [__] train i didn't
have the glasses
and i you know i can't see and i'm like
what the [__] and i'm crying
and the sheriff was like what i said man
i can't find my glasses
why are you watching about this [__]
got on the guy they gave me the guy
i mean that was they were so and i
couldn't go back and tell the guy he
gave me a [__] 600 pair of glasses
for free
and i [__] lost him come back to
other people over the hippy kitchen
the same thing they got me they got me a
nice pair of glasses
i went to go donate plasma one day and i
used to when i go donate platinum i get
me a bit of liquor and i sit down and
i'll call everybody because i i'm too
coward to call anybody any other time
that's something drinking slipping over
[__]
by the way is my birthday and they had
to dare me i had to drink it three days
which is a good thing that's why i'm
talking now but i
damn i sure wish i had but anyway so i'm
sitting there on it and
we don't my glasses are really thick so
they're uncomfortable
so i guess when i i take them off still
let my eyes let my
moles rest and i'm sitting there
drinking and this girl walks by and i'm
trying to i'm trying to holla at her
and her brother's telling me you're
alone because she's too young and off
she got a nice ass i want to get rid of
anyway he wants to beat me up
so anyway i run from him i run from him
and get on the orange line
they're thinking you know i don't have
no [__] ground i left my glasses on
the goddamn fence
so that was two pair of glasses that i
just i just took off and lost
so that was when i was homeless i'm
walking around blind you know when i
can't
i just i just you know let me know when
i when i was homeless
when i was homeless i was always worried
about somebody somebody you know one one
night they were there what they were
the one time there was a guy it would
skip through slayer what they would skip
was
afraid of what they said he was and one
night i was asleep
and that son that son of a [__] walked
up i know
[__] well he did cause i was cause i
was out he was setting people on fire
what he was doing
i was asleep one night i was down on
such as i was just i was down on
citizens
when i said when i sleep i go down i go
where the white folks
i don't go i don't sleep down here with
the ratchets i go way up my way up where
you
you know so i know they never bothered
me because i'm by myself you know i go
up there and smoke my crack drink my
liquor
and my clothes everything anyway i'm
over here and
this guy walks up on me and you know i
just wanna if i'm asleep
i don't have an instinct that just could
just slap and just [__] wake me up
and i don't know what [__] woke me up
that night i woke up and there's
somebody this son of a [__] was
standing over me like this he had a
goddamn pack of matches in his hand
that son of a [__] was gonna put me on
fire i know he was i said man you better
get up
i didn't have anything i said man you
better get your [__] outside
before i [__] you up
but that scared me so bad you know what
i mean oh that scared me so bad
and one time i'll sleep and the guy come
down
and he just kept walking by he just kept
walking by
and just kept walking by and he had a
crystal pipe
he said man you want to smoke some
bristles yeah he said well let me suck
your dick i said man [__] you i ain't
doing all [__] [__] like that
give me a hit as a goddamn fight [__] it
give me a hit and fight any god damn way
that's some [__] you do when you get hot
[__] it give me the goddamn fight
do whatever you're gonna do i don't know
i ain't doing you you do i don't give a
[__]
that's the kind of [__] that that's
another thing i never another thing i
never told you i was talking about that
so now i sit up here with all this [__]
all this [__]
up well let me get back to my family
i'll give you my friend now my sister
this [__] [__] she takes my daughter
i have my daughter my daughter
my daughter i had my name
percy my name and what's your mother's
name she changed her name and said oh
that name is ghetto we changed the name
i called her and told her several times
have her call me asap when she needs
something
she won't call me not once so she sent
me a little [__] up text
[__] my sister sent me a little [__]
up text
never mind i'm good i'm all right if not
if
if cause i said what did you never ask
your phone i'm gonna match my [__]
phone my phone never [__] ring
dumbass that's what i'm thinking myself
i won't talk mom like that's what i want
to say to her
but my [__] sister and his [__]
[__] she kept me a little
some of those cheap ass [__]
texts oh my god
it makes my head hurt because i don't i
don't i don't know why my fam my family
is just my family that's how
how how how is black say my friend
kicked me to the kisser you know what
i'm saying
and i sit up here and tell [__]
i don't give a [__] [__] them i don't
give a [__] i do give a [__]
i do give a [__] i mean that's my
[__] family dude hell yeah i'll
give her a [__] [__] but i just
act like i don't that [__] hurts that
your [__] people will call you
your [__] birthday and say hey man
i'm just calling hey man
hey but she was she that [__] [__]
she could have called me and said hey
man
didn't give a [__] i got shot
i come over that goddamn bridge on 7th
street one there and somebody's pulled
up in the car and
tried to kill me right here on [__]
7th street
and the [__] i saw my sister and
my daughter
two years later they didn't even
[__] know i didn't know you got shot
when did you get shot
i just looked at the [__] don't even
ask me the [__] question because if you
gave a [__]
you'd investigate it and find out where
the [__] i was you know what i'm saying
so they don't give a [__] i never did
nothing to them
you know but that that that that that
[__] hurts me now my birthday hurt me
today
i'm supposed to be happy my birthday but
i'm sad and i'm depressed
and i'm angry and i don't want to choke
somebody out
i want to go to the bank of jackson
[__] i
[__] i can't [__] sleep i ain't
sleeping three days maybe
maybe one or two hours i watch the
[__] me tv because i like the old
programs
they keep my mind off of [__] like
watching the gilligan's island and fred
flintstone and all that kind of [__] cuz
i don't know [__] they got on tv now i
know what the [__] what the [__] they
got on tv now
but anyway that kind of mellows me out
puts me to sleep
i used to take the medication because
they gave me they gave me
psych match a couple people have asked
me was i was psyched that's why i know
i'm going crazy
last week somebody asked me to report
that somebody asked me you had a
grooming room
she said do you think psych match you
know my my one of my friends he's
ordering
from drinking when they he's hey man you
take psych man you be trippin you know i
so
so people been kind of pulling my
coattail
but the reason why because the main
thing is wrong with me
is i suffer from anxiety i can't i
remember my friend told me
you got so many things racing through
your mind all the time you need to just
stop and just catch one
and hold on to it and and concentrate on
i can't do that i've never
ever ever when i was in school dude i
just studied to get a [__] d
i mean i had to say hard to get a
[__] d i couldn't i couldn't
you know i was thinking about when i was
in when i was in the fourth [__]
grade
my [__] nose and i was in
10th grade out of 11 classes i failed
six of them it was f
f f and i remember on the proxy report
card
the teacher would label me out will not
listen
does not understand does not focus
will not study never does homework
now obviously
i've always felt different there was
something there's there's some there's
something wrong with that
there's something wrong if a child if i
had a child who he had who suffer from
his symptoms
there's something there's something you
know i told my older brother he died
god bless him i told him i said i said
man i said i said
you know i used to get ssi check i said
i said that means it's something
something something don't click right
now i don't so that means i don't kick
like everybody else
if if i did i would i wouldn't they
wouldn't they gave me one
he looked at me oh no
that just he still that's just in the
shoes i just said she [__] that that's
the goddamn truth you know what i'm
saying
i can i could never get good grades in
school and i
i don't play bad listen this this [__]
sports oh my god i was the last one to
get picked up when you
when all the kids lined up and they get
picked we pick you we pick you with
people i would pick you big dude they
never pick me hello
matter of fact i'm still standing out
there somewhere i'm
[Laughter]
you know i i you know it's like it's you
know i was watching a program on tv
i'm feeling better i'm starting making
fun of it i'm watching a program on tv
and there's this kid right and he's
talking about he sees his ghosts
and then it was praying all my
activities whatever but anyway
one day that they had a camera on him
and they were it was some of the white
fear was falling behind the kid
and i had one of them [__] that
[__] was black
and that [__] didn't follow me
from day one when i was born i was born
blind
i was always running this [__] i was
always losing i was getting my ass
kicked when i fight
i have no confidence in winning it i
haven't i have but
you know i i managed to i managed to get
a girlfriend i managed to get some gum
i don't know i managed to get some good
girls some girls with jobs and girls are
that girl
hey guys some girls would ass some girls
with a job
and because and because some pretty
white girl i think it's a pretty white
girl but they don't last for a week two
weeks
but nowadays back in the day i was a
stood i was i was i was long digging man
i was awkward
man i used to i i was a jiggle i was a
[__] straight out
[__] big dick jiggle now goddamn that
[__] i need a pair of tweezers
to find that some [__] i can't girls be
like nah
girl now the girls they come to my house
i'm scared
they think i'm giggling i don't try to
[__] him at first because i'll be scared
my dick ain't nothin
when you get when you get 58 years old i
don't give a damn what you talking about
when you drink like i do another damn
thing you ain't getting your [__] man
i'm about my brother he gave me
biography one day
i got to god therefore i said well let
me see i took the [__]
i got a headache so goddamn oh man i got
the biggest guy that had it
it took three days for the goddamn thing
to work the girl was in the bed goddamn
she lay in the bed man come on man she
or she hide her [__] she's drunk
then she won't she won't she went to get
busy i can't do a [__] thing
i can't find my dick and then when i
i had an ex-girlfriend of mine one time
she didn't she knew because i was she
knew me with my big dick i had she want
me for
a matter of fact one day [__] one day
i was i never told anybody
one day i was [__] her and i missed a
[__] so my dick went in her ass right
and i didn't know i i don't i don't i
don't do that [__] but i didn't know but
i went in her ass and just
ah goddamn you could have heard her
scream goddamn people
i said what the [__] happened she said
you went in the real horse said that in
the wrong way i took it out some green
[__] was on my damn dick i'll never
forget that [__]
that was the nastiest grossest worship
but anyway
i [__] her again and we
well within a few years and she said
you ain't you you know you where where's
your dick
what's that whatever your dick i don't
know i don't know i said i guess i sold
it to the dope man
i don't know where the [__] is
but anyway um i'm not that big of a
study but
the good thing i want to say myself
people i love
you know i'm more i'm more proper
popular in my i'm more popular now than
i ever in my life
even though my [__] my family [__] my
father
[__] my mother [__] my sister [__] my
brother [__] them all
because i have people coming to me hey
man they see me talking on youtube
and all this thing and i appreciate it
when y'all i appreciate when y'all come
home with me and i really do because it
makes my day
i love to come here and talk my friend
here sesame do his talking he just he
doesn't know how much
he better i feel when i come in this
[__] goddamn
i feel like a new man now i feel like go
out and now i thought i'd go ahead and
have me a good day birthday
and uh have a good day well thank you
but i got i got i got
i got i gotta let y'all let me see every
time i come i got to make up a rhyme
i got to do it one two three four five
and every [__] time
i don't know what we're going to do on
the sabbath k
day but today is my [__] 58th
birthday i don't give a [__] if you
don't like it i don't give a [__] if you
don't call
but you ain't gonna see my name on no
bad for [__] wall i'm gonna try
to find me some [__] and get my rent
paid to get me some drink today
and [__] every goddamn thing else i'm
gonna say hey hey hey
we'll see y'all next time
was that cool okay
i made you laugh
you